awesome cool all right actually first of
all thanks so much for coming I have the
worst time for the session so I'm so
grateful that you guys make it I know
I'm sitting between you and the Pyke's
so hopefully it it will be worth your
time I'm a Technical Evangelist actually
software engineer part of technical
energy evangelist team at AWS
I specialize mostly in distributed
systems resiliency work quite much with
our reliability team Amazon in AWS are
working at trying to figure out how do
we scale systems and if you look at
these three a little bit of system this
is just to give you an idea of what
we're dealing with when we started kind
of Amazon back in the days in 1994 it
was a big Java monolith application and
we went into splitting that into a set
of micro-services fact there's about
1500 something micro services that serve
as the amazon.com website today no one
really knows the number of Mike services
it goes up and down regularly Twitter
Netflix very similar right so this tons
of micro services everywhere in fact
this is the extreme right but what we
say is if you give an architect about 10
different micro services it becomes very
very difficult for him already trying to
make sense of it how things work
actually we say that about three or four
systems is enough to create big
confusion in the minds right and most of
the service we build nowaday actually
have more than four five systems so it's
very we easily go into the realm of
complex systems and when we go in the
realm of complex systems in systems with
hundreds or thousands of micro services
it's actually very normal to have at any
given time many of those services that
don't work or that fail and we call that
partial failure mode it's actually this
is a representation of what partial
failure mode
means when you run that in production
this is actually in India and they do a
tire repair while the the mud is still
it is still running and this is actually
a working system right it still moves
forward discouraged people it just has a
little problem which is being fixed in
production it is exactly how we run
large-scale software systems all the
time
sinks fails right so we always have to
deal with those failures at any given
moment so why I'm telling you this I'm
telling you this because actually
resiliency is exactly that art is the
art of being able to run system with
failures on hand especially how to go
around conditions where you can't
predict especially how do you deal with
unexpected condition how do you recover
from that from them and how do you move
forward so this talk actually is about
some of the patterns we've seen through
our customers some of the patterns we
use at AWS to build services for you so
there's a bunch of those that I will
discuss and show you how we build
software system that scales to millions
some of them are very simple some of
them are genius in my opinion but more
because they are simple I think people a
lot of the time people think about
large-scale system as being very
complicated actually if you can simplify
them usually that's what is genius this
talk wouldn't have been possible with
all the pretty simple engineers that
work in Amazon there is hundreds of
those we often run talks inside Amazon
to discuss how we build stuff to share
cultures many of those ideas don't come
from me directly come from the folks
actually been working in Amazon and for
the last 20 years so I just want to call
out some of my favorite on these ones
especially that contributes a lot about
how Amazon
and they're on Twitter especially calm
always as very interesting stories on
Twitter so I highly recommend to go
follow that guy before I go into
discussing those patterns I'll give you
ten of those and you might want to take
them home and try to implement but
actually even implementing them doesn't
necessarily solve all the problem what
we're figuring that figure out is
actually the most important thing is the
habit right is how do you build habits
within your team to actually build
quality software
it goes from writing code to code review
to thinking about the overall system so
actually building that habit or quality
habit is often more important than
trying to implement a particular pattern
those patterns are good as a direction
to go
but don't forget that actually to
implement a good pattern and to make it
sustainable you need to have all the
ecosystems around okay so we're gonna
review ten of those before I dwell in
dwell into the first one I want to
remind you the famous nines of
availability I think when we talk about
resiliency and when we talk about
software it's super important to
remember what it means actually in the
industry it's very common nowadays to
claim that we have four or five nines of
availability that means actually you are
between 15 minute to 5 minute of
downtime a year which is ridiculous in
terms of abilities is very very good in
practice very very hard to implement in
fact I can tell you one of the some of
the outage I've lived seven years ago
our escalation path actually failed
while we had a cascading failure inside
the system so it was a double failure
and it took 27 minutes for us to notice
that there was a cascading failure in
the system in fact it was a customer
that did call us and say your system is
not working actually the escalation pass
I've failed as well so it was you know
already we had already blown off of the
credits for our 4/9
right so at the end of the day remember
that value and when you design system be
humble with them because they'll catch
you back very fast and one of the thing
I want to talk about every ability is
actually related to mathematics this
equation an is the equation of parallel
systems and it's an equation that
actually is at the heart of everything
which is happening in the cloud most of
the time when you talk about duplicating
workloads
if you take a part and you give it like
99% of F ability which is really really
bad because it means that particular
part is able to be down for about three
days 15 hours a year that's a lot your
customers are not going to be happy if
you give them this kind of availability
but if you take that component and
actually you don't do anything else but
you duplicate it you make it redundant
you all of a sudden increase it to 52
minute
downtime a year so it's dramatic
reduction if you make it three times you
actually go straightaway to six nines of
availability actually these ideas of
duplicating is at the heart of every
service we built right actually ls3
every bility durability is all based on
this kind of redundancy and it's also at
the heart of how we build our regions so
we have 19 different geographic regions
on AWS and I want to tell you a little
bit how we build a region because it's
very related to mathematics a region is
a set of data centers and those data
centers are grouped in what we call
availability zones so if you use AWS you
often see everybody's on ABCD in fact
just a pro tip if you see availability
in u.s.
1a and you say 1a it doesn't mean it's
the same every ability under the hood
right we actually switch those
for resiliency purposes because people
would tend to selects always the one a
or to be so if we make actually make
them random under the hood we increase
that the distribution of customers
across those davidann but all those AZ's
they are jig or geographically separated
in fact they are separated by few
kilometers usually one or two
millisecond latency and this is so that
we can do synchronous replications
between this is easiest right so we have
a regional split bit with three or more
AC some of the big regions at seven aces
an AC is actually a unit of capacity we
usually tend to limit our AC to a
certain capacity if we need to increase
that we build another AZ it is the same
one AZ can be one data center up to
several data centers as well and our
data centers we usually limit them to
50,000 servers something like this
so a Z's which are although all the Z's
have a lot of data centers in them right
sometimes up to 10 or more so this is
this is very important and each of those
aces are actually linked by very high
speed network so that we can actually do
very very good networking high speed
networking in replication
now the first patterns that we use
actually that also we recommend all our
customers to use is when you build
application is actually leveraged death
because by leveraging the three aces
like this you can use the mathematics of
redundancy right so if you have an
application and it's only one AZ then
your ability is usually not very good
especially it's it's blast radius is
quite high so we always say to our
customers and we also do inside for
building services for you that we
actually deploy our application across
multiple aces so this is the first
patterns we do very often
user database which is synchronously
replicated across several AZ so that is
there is an AZ that goes down actually
we can implement a failover to the other
region and the application will keep
working and this is very simple pattern
simply relying on mathematic now if you
take what if you take that it's very
good for polymers right because if one a
Z's go down well the other edges will
take over so most of our regional
service like dynamodb s3 of the e elby's
actually leverage this kind of stuff so
under the hood we also implement
services like this and this is also
detailing it's also detecting the kind
of service we are offering if you use
AWS you probably have noticed that we
have regional services like s3 DynamoDB
you can't decide which ACS
they are right by default there will be
spreading data and load across all those
phases but we also have what we call
zonal services which are actually very
dependent on the availability zone in
which you launch them like an instance
right you have to choose the AZ so the
kind of zomo service can't benefit from
this kind of multi AZ architecture so
what do we do with this so if you look
at the availability especially the blast
reduce of this kind of things for zonal
services or blast radius is actually
usually one AZ's so if we have a zonal
service and one particular ACS is
experiencing experiencing issues that
all AZ's will go down but the other
services will be able to recover right
if you use regional services now if you
have instances in this particular zone
and it experiences issue you can't
recover from it so this is kind of the
blast radius in that case for zonal
service is actually quite quite big now
the theoretical blast radius for
actually regional service
is is the biggest right so if if we have
regional services that goes down the top
layer which actually route the traffic
between different AZ's if this is
experiencing issue theoretically we
could average all failures in fact in
2007 we had nearly data plane
experiencing issues that took actually
some of the traffic out in the entire
region so the theoretical blast which is
pretty high now if you think a little
bit about how boats are constructed they
implement what we call compartments
right bulkheads and those bulkheads are
actually very useful it didn't really
work out for Titanic but it could have
but imagine you actually have a hole in
in in the boat
the water will feel only one part of
that compartment eventually all those
compartments actually waterproof or the
the water won't go into the other
compartments so the boat will be
resilient to let's say a hole in part of
the box and this is being implemented
from the very early days off of
navigation and if you take that ID you
can actually use it into the cloud and
at AWS how we build our service we use
something called cell sail based
architectures a sail is let's take a
service for example an application that
is deployed across multiple AZ's we call
that we take that application and we
move this in what we call a sail right
so I'm reduce it a little bit for
clarity and what we do is we duplicate
that cell so instead of having one
application actually we have multiple
application compartmented in sales with
a very very thin routing layer actually
that routing layer as as little as
possible and tries to do it as fast as
possible
in fact that sails routing layer is also
implementing what we call cell
architectures so that in case of zulan
failure actually the sale router will
stay up and this is deployed in what we
call a regional service so now if you
think about sales and the availability
zone and you think about blast radius
actually if you have a regional service
initially having an issue in the Celebes
architecture you actually are able to be
resilient because now instead of having
one big regional service you have
multiple sale that serve that service
and for us we build all our services
like this so most of that's kind of
architectures you can also implement
that actually using DNS so for example
if you make a request to route 53 you
can compartiment
that you know weezing weezing a sale and
then allocate some of these users to
these kind of different sales right so
this is very easy to implement as well
so these these services allow you to
implement kind of resiliency arm both
regional and zonal level okay and of
course it also allows you to have
resiliency to partial failures because
now you have multiple sale for each of
the races so if one sale is expanding
issues the other sales are not affected
because they are like bulkhead they are
not they don't have any relations to
each other now the system property is
very interesting because of course you
have work for workload isolation right
you have failure competition so that if
you have a failure in one of those sales
it doesn't propagate to the others the
other one still stay up and running but
this sale actually for us are really
interesting for another dimension for
scaling up actually instead of scaling
up in terms of power or you know
instance was well what we call scaling
up
we scale out so we take a sale language
therapy that sales will have a maximum
number of users will have a maximum
number of servers and then if this
increases will actually will add other
sales and actually some of the biggest
service have thousands of sales right so
this is actually very interesting for us
because now those sales allow us to also
do rollout by while limiting the blaster
use because now we can roll out per
sales and we can notice there are issues
in each of the cells if there are issues
we can roll back easily the blasts
reduce is Contin eyes like is minimum we
also actually do what we call chaos
engineering in those cells so that we
can test in real production data how
things really behave so that means we
are able to understand a system within
the cell and then replicate that into
other cells because we always have a
maximum capacity for cell once we
understand it very well we can replicate
that learning from one cell to the
others so this is very interesting for
us in terms of testability and
manageability and of course when you
want to understand how a system behaves
it's a lot easier to have a smaller cell
and trying to dig out digging into how
the system behaves with ended cells
which maybe has thousand people and
thousand servers versus a cell which has
10,000 servers and millions of people
so the logs all these kind of things
it's much more manageable so this is
very important for us
now there's another pattern that is very
interesting is let's take for example an
application and if I have an application
and I have eight different users right
so each of the icons is a particular
user now say my user one of the user is
experiencing issues or for example it
makes a query that damages the backend
you know this kind of expensive queries
which hit the particular bug which
actually take down things
easily well what often will do this
request will eat one server the server
will go down because it was a very
expensive request that happens very
easily now the user usually has a retry
right so we'll eventually retry and
actually take down all the other servers
and these conditions are very common and
there are you know maximizing the
blaster it is to pretty much all the
servers right so the blast radius is
affecting all the customers here so all
the customers will suffer from one
particular request that one user as as
made and this is very common that's what
we call cascading failures cascading
failures representing I think it's very
easy to understand cascading failure
when you look at this mom if you think
about having a load balancer be a load
balancing load between two servers she
hits a condition where one of the server
is in in stable and that moves all our
attention to the other server is
creating overload and taking it down as
well and this is exactly what these
conditions happen it doesn't have to be
big big problems on with the instance
sometimes really just a particular bug a
query the way you a condition that you
haven't tested can degenerate
very easily and take whole clusters down
in matters of minutes so to prevent
these kind of things we also we
implement this kind of cell based
architectures as well for our our
customers so instead of having all the
customers being able to utilize a
cluster of instance what we do is we
compare to my comp complete
compartmentalize this cluster into cells
and we assigned for example a sale to
the same user and this this time the
blast radius is actually going to be
only one user affected so the other are
not going to be affected by that
particular dangerous query so the
is something that we do for all our
services ISO to limit the path less
radius and in that case actually the
blast radius all of a sudden becomes 25%
instead of hundred percent so we have a
factor for improvement but that's
actually not not all you can do a lot
better and this takes me to the third
pattern pattern that we really like
ratable s what we call shuffle charting
shuffle charting is very simple instead
of allocating a user to the entire set
of cluster or to a cell we actually
randomize user for a particular instance
and actually we assign this user to two
particular instance in that case and
then all other users we also randomize
but what you realize is actually by
doing by doing this now if I have an
expensive query about the same user the
blast radius of course will take down
the server's here but the same user is
now the heart will just make a retry and
we have be able to have a successful
request to the other servers and
actually in that case it's very
interesting because our blast radius is
now the number of customers divided by
the combinations that we have done the
shuffling right so in that case if you
have eight nodes and you have shard size
of two your percentage of or your blast
radius is three point six percent so we
went from 125 to three point six percent
and it's quite interesting because you
only had eight nodes and your
combinations already 28 different
combinations right so if you have
thousands of of those nodes the blast
radius goes close to zero point
something percent so this is very very
useful patterns that you can also use to
do that again you can we do the shuffle
based on particular ash which assigned
sir to servers to that particular users
and then render minds the rest it's kind
of random kind of not this Ash's is
actually depending on the service can
can vary but you can think of it as a
random shuffling and this is the math
the mathematic equation behind so
something very interesting and what it
does is actually yeah this is actually
the number of for a hundred of those the
number of a combination is 75 million
therefore your last reduce is close to
nothing really
so shuffle shutting is very interesting
because it gives us very mean minimum
blast radius the only thing it requires
very simple it just requires a client to
do retry because if one request fails
then you will have to retry that
particular request student to another
servers it works for a lot of different
things like servers queues or a
synchronous systems we actually use many
many different places both from the
route 53 to 2 s 3 to 10 ml d be
different services to be able to
distribute the loads and of course you
need a routing mechanism which you have
ok so this is very interesting one now
you've probably all heard about auto
scaling and auto scaling is mostly known
for being able to adapt an
infrastructure to the load that it
receives right so for example you have
maybe a traffic peak traffic during day
time and then all your traffic goes very
low during the night so you bring back
you bring up resources during the day
and then shut them down automatically
during the night and this is very common
way of auto scaling but actually in my
opinion is not the best way of it what
is very interesting with auto scaling is
that you can assign a minimum resource
right so for example in that case it's
just
I'm an example if I have two servers
distributed across two aces and I set
the minimum of instances to super to
zero by default the system will self
heal
so if actually one of the instance go
down automatically the load balancer
will take it out of the of the of the
application and will terminate it and
then automatically come back up and this
is my opinion very interesting a very
simple thing to do like the basic of
self-healing systems right and then
eventually the load balancer will do
some health check figure out nuts this
is a new instance so we'll bring it back
up inside the the load balancer auto
scaling group even this even though this
feature has been out for about six years
I it's still very common that customers
don't know about it so I think this is
very important that you know and
actually we do use that pattern
extensively inside AWS in Amazon as well
this is an accelerated video of how this
work so this I have a load balancer
which which has instances I kill an
instance and here you see the system
terminates the instance you see is
shutting down here and the system
realizes that actually one of the
instance is going down and ultimate
automatically will bring that instance a
new instance back up and this really
happens in a matter of minutes so very
interesting features that that you need
to leverage you see it's automatically
launching a new one so very simple and
yet very very very useful the pattern 5
is about decoupling a synchronous or
decoupling services from each other I
think very it's been very common back in
the day to have synchronous systems
where you make a query you wait for the
query to execute and then
come come back when that query has been
executed now the problem is if my
process B doesn't resolve that doesn't
respond in time or is slow my process a
will suffer so you have coupling of
processes or services and this is
terrible so we move extensively to a
synchronous patterns actually most of
the backend framework and front-end
framework dos support this kind of
pattern but what we really really like
and what I suggest you should think of
is actually decoupling what we call the
API the API layer from the business
logic if you look at sets of API in an
application I think very often many of
those don't need to be synchronous a
very very few need to be synchronous
like for example bank transactions you
probably want that to be synchronous and
make sure that that transaction happened
but most of the other you can do it as
synchronously it doesn't mean then you
show it as not synchronous requests to
the end-user you can hide the in sakra
Nissa T in the UI make it look like that
it's synchronous that's what or
Instagram Facebook and application that
where you upload videos do what you need
to do this because it allows you to do
very interesting things for example you
see in that case have an API and I
assign it a job ID in that case in our
return immediately
now that job of forced goes in and queue
most of the a synchronous patterns in
the cloud are using queues so you put
that job in the queue and then you have
kind of a group of working instances or
that implement business logic that take
that job and execute it and now you
might think that actually I it's slower
because you have another three parts but
it's actually very often as fast a
synchronous operation because you can
scale you can scale both both clusters
on from independent from one another for
example worker instance are often
cpu-intensive whereas api instances are
more memory intensive because you have
to open web sockets and things other you
have to open network sockets which take
memories and then after a particular
load as a massive effect on the on the
on how your instances behave but this is
very interesting so you're working
instance take the job from the queue and
then once they've executed the job just
store that in a cache and then you can
actually send a notification to the end
user say oh your result is able we'll
come and fetch it this is cool and these
patterns is used extensively all over
the place what I really like about this
pattern is actually then you can
implement degradation and
prioritizations so now imagine you're
your back-end or your applications or
service is experiencing experiencing a
slowdown very common practice is
actually to do request cancellation and
so the services down we contact requests
so try later
and you see these all over the place now
you can actually take the idea of ok
what are the API is what are the
functions in my application which can be
priorities priorities always versus the
others and then you can take that idea
of prioritization actually build several
queues a high priority queue low
priority do it when you can kind of
queue so you can actually scale the
queue in terms of priorities and then do
service degradation so for example
instead of saying oh you come access
Netflix because the authentication
system doesn't work you say okay I'm
gonna degrade and I'm gonna go into an
open and open systems but still handle
API calls that do start videos or things
like this and then under the hood start
fixing the backend in fact many of the
services we build as well are based on
this kind of pattern so we try to
understand what are the api's that are
really important and how we want to
prioritize those api's into
case of failures and this is very
interesting now I want to talk a little
bit about time outs and retry because in
these systems it's very important to add
them in place so let's take a simple
example of users connecting to an
application that connects to a back-end
okay now in that makes queries to a
database
now imagine that database at some point
starts to slow down so what happens well
what happened actually it's a very
interesting question there's tons of
things can happen right what we're
talking about retries and time out so
first thing that you have to figure out
is actually what are the timeouts
involved right so you look at the
timeouts on the clients eyes you look at
the timers in the backend size and very
often if you ask teams it's the first
question Michael oh not sure actually
the default huh okay default so let's go
with default ok let's have a user one
make a query to the app that app make an
insert to database that database slows
down well mines first slows down right
eventually if I have a time out of ten
seconds but my inserts as a default
timeout well you don't know when is
what's gonna happen basically eventually
this one will timeout or not if your
timeout is twenty thirty one minute or
infinite this connection will stay open
and actually the client will time out
and make a retry all right so my client
makes you retry my connection is still
open to the database I'll make another
Rick retry now the inserts same behavior
my query slows down doesn't timeout my
client retries and retry and you see at
some point you'll have something like
this right so
how many of you have seen that message
right failed to get connection from
pause so that means you've exhausted the
number of connections available to your
database and now actually your users
cannot even make requests to the
application and this is actually a very
very common patterns to having cascading
failures because actually that user and
we'll do a retry the application cannot
be contacted so the load balancer will
push that to another servers and the
same patterns will happen actually I've
seen 120 day servers database servers go
down in literally less than 30 minutes
because of that so this is very very
dangerous pattern now you might be
wondering why did the hell I put a
timeout of infinite well actually how
many of you are Python developers here
yeah I mean your view are no the gdbg
drivers for not sequel silence anyone
want to take a guess what kind of
timeouts we have for most of the
actually language and defaults well
actually it's infinite you'll be scared
to actually look at documentation
request time' is the most used library
for python to do requests default
infinite no sequel default 0 which means
infinite right actually 80% of the
frameworks i've used usually I have a
default timeout of zeros and actually if
you go to customers and you're in
software teams most of the time people
don't know that's actually a big big
problem and has been responsible for
many many outages outage that I've
experienced so in Python you would do
something like this you put a decorator
and you do what some retry you say let's
do five retry after five retry you
actually cancel the request in
cancellation is actually very very good
something that should be implemented you
should never ever have a client which
one definitely it's the best way to
never recover from an outage because
then your infinite number of customers
make
in retries your system tries to come
back up goes down immediately after so I
have a maximum number of time out of
retries make them time out okay so
release them but that's actually not it
there's a another thing that could have
been don't prevent that to happen from
happening well this really tries that
good but actually you should never retry
immediately right you should do what we
call back off and there's several ways
to do back off my coffees I'll make a
request if it fails I'll wait for
example two seconds and do retry if my
request fails again I'll try four
seconds if it fails again I wait eight
seconds we call that exponential
back-off but actually exponential
back-off again is not necessarily the
best you see the good thing with back
off here is that after four requests if
I have a timeout back in of ten seconds
eventually we'll start releasing
database connections right so eventually
your servers won't be so overloaded or
won't start canceling requests but
that's not enough actually there is a
very interesting paper which we we wrote
about exponential back-off
in and how it behaves at large scale and
if you look at a classic back of
algorithm which is simply exponential
back-off and you put it in kind of
distributed systems eventually all the
retries will still be clustered in kind
of funnels right they will all have this
kind of happen more or less at the same
time and this is very interesting it's
very interesting properties of
exponential back-off in distributed
systems is they actually are not random
most of the time the reach wise will
happen at the same times across the
network and will sink rise so what we
figure out there is actually a very
simple way to
itemized exponential back-off is to add
a jitter so inside inside your slip
function for example you are actually a
random or a jitter that kind of
randomize a little bit your retry and
now if your Python again there are some
interesting patterns that actually use
that full jitter there's a paper written
about it if you are interested you
should definitely really because it's
very very interesting with all the math
behind it now of course if you're doing
retry you have to use in deponent
operations independent operations means
that for any given retry a request will
always have the same behavior but now it
does have a problem right if I have a
retry and I have if I have a request
that writes to database my request
actually can fail on the client-side on
the backend side how do I know in case
of failures that actually the request
has been executed if you have
independent operation you might have ten
ten different inserts and that will blow
up your database as well so you need to
have a mechanism for example through a
query ash so you ash or you try to
identify queries you you hash a query to
track it across this is it's passed and
figuring out is has been executed so
there's tons of operations to do at
scale to be able to figure out is
actually if we try has been executed or
not and it's not a simple problem it can
make system quite complex but it's
something you have to take into
consideration so doing timeouts and
retry is good doing an important
operation is good but make sure that
actually operation doesn't blow up your
database so make sure that you can try
you can figure out if a request has been
successful or not so there is some some
different strategy there's a bucket
strategy so you
with a token in a bucket for each
request it have been successful you
remove it from the bucket interesting if
you are interested into that pattern
Google as a as tons of answer around on
Google search and of course in
distributed system there's another thing
you need to work with so if I have a
client and I want to do retries it's
probably a good idea that my client has
an ID of what's the condition of the
network right so very often distributed
systems will have health checks we all
have built health checks for our
operations even for our systems now
there is different type of health checks
there is like what we call the shallow
health checks and the deep health check
so the shallow health check in that case
if I have an issue in my application say
for example the the the shallow health
check will check the instance and say my
instance is up and running I'm all good
and actually will return all good even
if for example email servers is down
because it's a shallow we doesn't go and
check further down the stream if you
want to figure out further down the
stream what you the conditions of
network you have to implement deep
health checks right so for example a
health check that will propagate to all
the others services often a
synchronously figuring out the condition
come back to the instance and say yeah
everyone is up and running you can pass
it back we're good so where should you
employ the deep health check and when
she do shallow health check actually a
very very very complicated question
shallow health check is very good for
figuring out networking issues like for
example say my instance is having
security group networking issue cannot
access the database you know something
like this or that this
resource-constrained doesn't have enough
memory doesn't that is enough CPUs so it
doesn't answer my health check in time
start to timeout this is interesting now
it's very bad
for understanding the network condition
so you know for example shallow health
check would have said my instance is
healthy and if you will have an API that
ask to sent an email your email wouldn't
have been sent for example whereas the
dippers check will check the condition
of that email server and returns are you
healthy of course I'm not healthy now
you might also think okay but that's
actually a problem right because which
service actually in in the holes system
are critical is actually an email server
critical to your application so that for
health check you should say no not
healthy so don't send me traffic I
cannot send the emails well no right so
very often what you want to do is have a
prioritization of your system thinking
out is it a critical service is it not
critical what should I do if I have
email server going down should I
actually report that I'm and healthy or
should I just do an asynchronous call to
a queue that will allow work instance to
take that job and send the job to email
server in guess in case this is healthy
oh when it goes back online right so
that discussions needs to happen right
it's not just straightforward to say oh
I want to use I want to do a health
check is you have to think carefully
which one to use deep health checks are
very good for when the system is running
when the cache has been warmed up to
figuring out if actually your
application can do complex queries but
it's very bad
I'd start up a start up time if a cache
is not warmed up or if downstream
services take a bit longer to start your
instance is healthy and then your deep
health check will return not available
because my cluster for example takes
time to start so actually this is very
important to do so when you have an
architectures and when you build
microservices try to build a map of
critical services how your API
map to that sir to that service path
which coal should be a synchronous
because in that case you very easy to
say my email server is actually not
critical instead of having your health
check our health check your queue for
example say oh can I take the job of and
then make an asking for news call to
queue and then send that to your servers
they should absolutely not be not
billing and it might be trivial but
actually very very often you see you see
through health check couplings of
services which you don't necessarily
think of so many of the problems have
been fixed inside in the architectures
I've seen in the last 15 years by doing
this kind of very simple mapping of
health check and how do we behave other
service criticals or not and this health
check actually should not just be an
information for instances in the cloud
actually you should bring back that
information especially information for
deep health check bring it back to the
clients because they are very very
useful to do service degradation
so take the UI of Netflix for example
actually when you scroll the UI it's
composed of many different let's say
micro services like Rick that are
powered by recommendation engines like
trending now or you watch that movie so
you probably like this one this kind of
things right so there's about 150
services powering the UI of Netflix if
you have a deep health check that brings
back kind of information about the
condition of those critical service back
to the UI you are able to adapt the UI
and make the UI not show errors for
example right so you can hide you can
say okay if my if my service that is
recommending is not responding to a
health check well actually I'll just
cancel it no but you can do something
else as well
you can Dec take that information from
the deep health check and actually do
fall backs and this is very interesting
thing for example in that case if my
recommendation engine doesn't work you
would fall back to cash say o popular on
Netflix doesn't need any recommendation
engine is simply a value an array of
ideas in cash right so the whole thing
can be degraded simply because we have
done a deep health check and then return
that value into the arrived amazon.com
works like this as well will collapse
the UI will will do fallback in case of
some of the services downstream not
working properly or not returning to
create value and it's also very
interesting to spread load run if you
start identifying clusters in sales that
have in our sales architectures that has
its degradation of service you can
actually start moving traffic around so
that leads me to pattern 8 actually very
very common I'm sure all of you know
that pattern is using circuit breaker
right which a circuit breaker is simply
a way to decouple request from one
service to another and you kind of wrap
a request call inside an object that
objects monitor the conditions of the
downstream service that it wants to
connect to and if there is a lot of
different timeouts going above a
threshold you break the circuit now the
interesting part with this is actually
for developers because if you use
circuit breaker it forces developers to
think about fallback you say alright
when you create your object you have the
connection check monitoring that's fine
but your object needs a fallback what do
you do in case my circuit breaks so this
is why I really like that pattern and
now database a little bit very classic
patterns database Federation is a
classic way of looking at you know
spreading the load across different
database is very common in customers or
especially that scale to never touch the
database until the last moment because
everyone is scared of database actually
every companies I've worked with it's
always been like this
so I everything was beautiful and in the
database we can touch that piece man
so one of the simple patterns database
Federation when you look at queries
actually very often you will see that
tables don't necessary need to whole
database don't necessary Oh tables don't
need to be shared in the same database
because there are no join so performance
wise you actually can scale them
independently you might have users and
product and then have them scale
different different ways at Amazon in
2017 we actually analyzed as well the
database queries that were happening on
on the platform and 70% of them were not
transactional and guess what we were
using only transactional database right
that's crazy this is why we started the
whole dynamo Domino thing DynamoDB was
created simply because we actually
realized that patterns were not
transaction it was we had we were trying
to scale our transactional data is
actually Oracle database back in the
days and we had massive problem with
that because we were not using database
for what is good for another way to do
or to scale a little bit is charting
right this is very common when you have
global application you shard your
database per geography so for example
you say okay all my users in Europe will
go in a particular database or a
particular table and then you can split
them you can do Federation after that so
this is very common pattern but actually
very interesting patterns for resiliency
is and very simple is readwrite
separation and crazy enough it's very
rare that people implement that right so
if you are using RDS or or transactional
database
most of them support replicas right so
that means you can have a master
database which replicate data
synchronously or asynchronously to read
replicas so that means you can actually
preserve your master for all the rights
and then do the reads on the replicas of
course you are in the realm of eventual
consistency because your master and you
read replicas might not have exactly the
same value for particular data but is
price to pay for having this kind of
system resilient system and the
interesting thing with this is actually
you can fall back into read-only mode so
for example like Amazon amazon.com
business or let's say prime video is how
its implemented Prime video business is
actually to serve videos right now if
the database breaks should we forbid
everyone to watch videos because we
couldn't fall back now so if the
database for master falls down or if the
experiencing an issue or if we have to
maintain it if we have to change the
schema or something
we actually fall back into read-only
mode and that's it we suffer the
consequences for example well we won't
be able to track some particular type of
data at that time but as a user you can
still consume and this is the most
important right so this is actually very
interesting interesting pattern for
degradation and you should definitely
think about it when you design
application now continuing in the
database a very common pattern is
actually to store transient State in
database like values of counters I've
seen this ridiculously amount of time a
counter which usually use an update
queries update queries lock the table so
that means you cannot do writes on other
fields so that if you have a lot of
users or if your database starts to slow
down you're gonna have accumulation of
update queries eventually your database
will go down taking cascading failures
and boom-boom-boom I've seen this happen
all the time so use the database for
immutable data if you have data that is
gonna be mutated in
a minute 2 minute 5 minute it should not
bend a little bit because that scale
it's gonna break it's guaranteed
especially for sequel and transactional
database so transit state move that to
no sequel or email restore like you know
radius or memcache something like this
especially in distributed system but not
transactional for people very
interesting pattern is think about
firefighters right firefighters take
about 80 percent of the time to practice
fighting fire in an experiment condition
or in the test condition so they go into
a place train could fire and then try to
fight it and really pretty much 80% of
the time they do this and you know what
simply because they need to build what
we call intuition intuition for fighting
fighter firefighter if actually they
don't use intuition they will have to
think too much and it will be dead so
you have to take that patterns and
actually think about it in in terms of
architectures in systems and Amazon in
2017 we brought one of one firefighter
to actually lead the resiliency team
called Jesse Robbins he was a
firefighter and started to do what we
called game days back in the day game
days it was I it was literally going
around the datacenter pulling out cables
of stuff and figuring out what happened
of course he was a contained environment
we really tried to reduce the blast
reduce there's a legend I actually went
into breaking whole data center the
result was dramatic but they learned a
lot out of it and actually this practice
is still used today we do game days all
the time every time we launch a new
region we actually spend weeks and weeks
breaking things in figuring out if the
system is gonna be resilient Netflix
called that chaos engineering right
y'all know case engineering because of
the chaos monkey Netflix started
to do chaos monkey back in the days when
they started to replicate their
application across multiple regions and
having very complex architectures they
needed to start breaking things randomly
to see how the system was behaving and
actually they realized and you don't
listen see start which production
environment so don't go Monday and so
Adrian say we should do case engineering
let's break the data base in production
now start in a test environment build
confidence into the system figure out if
you have the right patterns if all those
patterns have been implemented if you've
thought about it if your timeouts are
correct if your retries are correct this
is the only place where you can actually
do real test is production eventually
and this is why all those patterns are
interesting multi AZ's sales because you
can have live traffic which has a very
limited blast radius you can figure out
where to do this of course doing a/b
testing or cannery deployments it's very
important for that as well so try to
experiment with chaos engineering chaos
engineering you need to figure out this
steady state of the environment and make
hypotheses and say oh how is my system
going to behave if I remove the database
if you ask all this is software engineer
in the company often everyone will give
a different answer you I will say
something the our designer will say
something the database guy will say
something the backing guy would say
something the manager will say something
that's actually very interesting data is
why is everyone having a different
answer and then take that data that's
enough to start with and then once
everyone has the same answer
then go and test it on check your
hypothesis and say oh actually is the
system really going into read-only mode
is my failover really happening after 60
seconds is my client really retrying is
my client really supporting read-only
mode what happens if I lose a DNS of all
the DNS address or domain name of my
database or if I change it actually back
in the day if you
using Java framework you had to restart
the whole framework to be able to update
the DNS there was no way to do a hot
reload all this kind of stuff was very
common in all frameworks to do this and
many systems still are like this and
there's only in these conditions where
you can actually test those so try to
experiment and think how chaos
engineering to do can I help you and
it's very simple case engineering it's
like vaccination you go into the system
and you inoculate with failures the best
one is latency latency is a deadly thing
it actually will take down system like
you've never seen before add 300
milliseconds latency to a back-end and
crazy things will happen in fact I'll
give you what we've noticed the Amazon
hundred percent 100 milliseconds license
increase on the UI add an effect of 1%
sale drop 100 milliseconds is something
the human eye can't even see right and
through experiment chaos and genuine we
realize actually 100 milliseconds Latins
the increase on the UI has an effect on
sales of 1 percent for each hundred
millisecond increase which is crazy at
the sales Amazon is a lot of money so
this is a very good way to do it but you
don't necessarily have to do like
applications on network or host failures
you can do people failure I love the
attack what I call the pole attack we
all have in our company a guy named Paul
Paul does everything he knows everything
how things work how they fix he takes he
looks at the problem fixes it and we
move on you know Paul you have a poll
right we all have those guys Paul give
me your laptop don't come to work today
superb attack actually I've seen company
fail miserably because of that and
that's the buzz factor right it's what
if Paul actually dies today what happens
how do we recover from that that fix
this region attacks once a month they
actually break the entire AWS region and
do traffic shift live in production
while you watch your movie that's how
good
become they've done they've been
practicing chaos engineering for about
seven eight years this is actually not
impossible it's something that you can
also aim for start small
I don't necessary to reach in right away
you know start small and then build
confidence again in my last advice
actually and this is totally related to
resiliency is always planned for the
worst
but be prepared for the unexpected
because that's didn't expected that will
break you in fact my last outage was a
squirrel eating electric cable and
that's how it happened so we never
thought about that okay thanks a lot and
thanks for staying here with me if you
want to read more about some of the
stuff I published quite much on medium
and that presentation is actually
already downloadable I just uploaded it
to speaker deck so if you want that you
can get it right away thank you very
much have a good evening enjoy your beer
[Applause]